MARTIN OMANDER: Hello.
My name is Martin
Omander, and I welcome you
to "Google Root Access,"
the show featuring
actionable startup advice.
My guest today is Jakob Berglund
from the startup Unified
Intents.
Jakob, tell us a bit
about your startup.
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah.
So we have created an app called
Unified Remote that basically
turns your smartphone
into a universal remote
for your computer.
So we support Linux,
Windows, and Mac.
And we give you remote
controls for different programs
on your computer.
So VLC, Spotify, iTunes.
And we also allow users to
create their own applications.
So you can basically
control anything
you like on your computer
from Unified Remote.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah.
So you're sitting in the couch,
and just pull out your phone,
and you control what music
plays on your computer.
JAKOB BERGLUND: Exactly, yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
I see.
So in the last episode, I spoke
with your co-founder, Philip,
and we spoke about
business stuff.
Let's talk about technology
this time around.
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
I'm an engineer.
I love talking about technology.
You're an engineer, too, right?
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah.
Exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So I went to the Play
Store and noticed
that you have 3
million downloads.
Quite impressive.
How did you get there?
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah.
Basically, we started early.
So we were a couple of months
into Android was released,
we released our app.
And that, of course,
gave us a big boost,
because we got all
the media attention
and because no one
else was on the store.
So no one else
was written about.
So every new cool app was
written quite a lot about.
And we also always listen to our
customers as much as possible.
So for support or
Google Analytics
or different kind of media.
MARTIN OMANDER: Mm.
Right.
So now Android has been
around for a little while.
What kind of new technologies
are you looking into now
to get that sort of
media boost again?
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah.
So we always look for
new, cool technologies.
You can't support
everything, but you
have to pick the best ones.
And right now, we're looking
to Android Wear, of course.
But also other
wearable technologies,
like Apple smart watch and--
MARTIN OMANDER: Mm.
That would be pretty cool.
You can sit on the couch and
control what music is playing,
or movie is playing,
on your watch.
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah.
Because we want
to make the remote
control as useful, or as
close to you as possible.
You should not have to
look for your remote.
So on your wrist, you will
probably not lose your wrist.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, right.
And you get that media hit
again from being among the first
on a new platform.
Sounds like.
Yeah.
So your app, I looked at it.
It contains many different
remote controls inside it,
plug-ins for controlling
Spotify and VLC and so on.
How do you decide which
pieces of software
to support within your app?
There's an infinite
number of apps out there.
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah, obviously.
So we started, of
course, with the big ones
like VLC or Spotify.
But then we listened to
our customers, of course.
And they requested quite a
lot of different applications.
So we started adding them.
And then we started
looking through Analytics
for which remotes
were used the most,
and try to find similar
remotes, but also
improve some
remotes that we see,
OK, this is not used that much.
Or this is really used, so
we have a lot of uses there.
Perhaps we should put even
more attention to that one.
Or that one is
not used too much,
so perhaps there is
something wrong with it.
And then we reduce to that one.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So you say Analytics.
What analytics are
you looking at?
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah,
Google Analytics.
So we look at which countries
are people coming from?
But also which
remotes are most used?
Which buttons are most
used in those remotes?
And as much information
as we can gain,
we try to use just to make
it as useful or as smooth
as possible for users to use.
MARTIN OMANDER: So this is
the normal Google Analytics
that you might install
on your website?
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah.
It's the same thing, but
it's a different SDK.
So just put in a JAR
file in your application,
and add some code.
There's a great guide
at Google, of course.
So you can just add it.
It's almost drag and drop.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, right.
Oh, so you just imported your
file in your Android project,
and then you have access?
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah.
Exactly.
So you add some small piece
of code, and everything works.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, right.
Are there any other insights
you get from Google Analytics
like how people find
the application,
or geography, or anything else?
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah.
Because we have a server
version, or a server
part of our software, we have
a website people have to use.
You have to get that server.
And then we see from which
countries or from which
links that people are
going to our website.
So we get quite a lot of traffic
there, and that, of course,
helps us also to-- oh, that
website has written about us.
Perhaps we could boost
that by just putting it
on Facebook or whatever.
So we always look
for all kind of data
to find interesting parts.
MARTIN OMANDER: Mm.
Right.
Great.
So finally, what
would your advice
be to a mobile startup
starting today,
when it comes to new technology
platforms and analytics?
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah.
Pretty much, start
as soon as possible.
You have to be first on market.
If you're first on market, you
will get the media attention.
But also, of course,
listen to your customers
and try to understand
what your customer needs.
And Google Analytics is
one way of doing that.
Of course, support and other
social media is also useful.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Great.
Thank you for sharing your
experiences with us, Jakob.
JAKOB BERGLUND: Yeah, thank you.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hopefully, you
found something useful there
that you can use
in your startup.
If you have comments
on the show,
please enter them in the
YouTube Comments section.
We read everything you write.
And finally, if you are
a high-tech entrepreneur,
go to
developers.google.com/startups
to find out how
Google can help you.
That's it.
See you next time.